lasers you can use them to cut things
you can use them to put at words and you
can use them to treat about a million
different skin related things these are
just the ones i saw on the aed website
there's different types of pigment and
red marks skin texture loose skin hair
removal and hair regrowth tattoo removal
so how does it work and does it hurt i'm
michelle of lab muffin beauty science
chemistry phd and cosmetic chemist and
today we're talking about laser skin
treatments i'm going to cover treating
ethnic skin which is particularly tricky
and my own experience with getting a set
of picosure focused laser treatments
what's involved how it feels whether it
hurts and the results this video is
sponsored by cynosure who make the
picosure laser that i was treated with
but as always this is all my own
research and honest opinions skin care
products are great but there's a limit
to how much they can do and how quickly
they can work in clinic treatments can
be a better option for a lot of things
and laser treatments are one of the most
popular as you can tell from the giant
list lasers are incredibly versatile
this isn't a complete list and lasers
aren't necessarily the only or the best
treatment for a lot of these but it
gives you an idea of the massive range
we're talking about
so what is a laser a laser is a machine
that shoots out light now it's not the
same as a torch the light has special
properties that make it really good for
skin treatments the light is very
aligned and in sync so the light is very
energetic and focused into a tiny area
it's also one color the light is a
particular wavelength having just the
one color of light means that you can
target specific things in the skin with
minimal impact on everything else in the
skin so you shoot light into the skin
with a laser and then something in the
skin will absorb the light and when
stuff absorbs light it converts it to
other forms of energy like heat if you
put a black thing in a white thing in
the sun the black thing heats up more
because black dye absorbs more light
energy and turns it into more heat
different things absorb different
wavelengths of light so if you shoot a
particular wavelength of light into the
skin a particular color of light that
melanin pigment absorbs but other things
don't really then that means the melanin
pigment gets blasted but other things in
your skin don't they have minimal damage
and most lasers work pretty much like
different colored things in the sun the
melanin heats up while the rest of your
skin stays mostly cool this is called
selective photo thermolysis you can
select one thing and use light to heat
it up until it breaks the thing that
absorbs the light the thing in your skin
that the laser is targeting is called
the chromophore apart from melanin the
other chromophores in the skin that
lasers usually target are hemoglobin the
red chemical in red blood cells and
water so to remove brown pigment patches
lasers target melanin to remove red
things like broken capillaries the
lasers are targeting hemoglobin
skin has a lot of water in it so the
lasers that target water cause
controlled damage to the skin in general
so that hopefully gets the skin to
repair itself in a good way like with
more collagen in a rejuvenating
treatment or to smooth out the surface
and reduce fine lines and scars which is
called laser resurfacing different
wavelengths also travel different
distances into the skin longer
wavelengths get deeper into the skin so
longer wavelengths are used in laser
hair removal they can get down deep
enough to heat up and kill cells in the
hair root which is all the way down here
in the dermis for epidermal pigment
that's a lot more shallow in the skin
you can use shorter wavelengths that
don't have to get down quite as far
apart from wavelength or color there are
tons of other settings that can be
adjusted to change how a laser works on
the skin there's the pattern of the
light whether it's a continuous beam of
light or whether it's short pulses how
long each of those short pulses are the
gap between the pulses how much the beam
is spread out and having so many options
means that laser results will depend a
lot on the skills of the person who's
using the laser on you that's why it's
really important to research properly
before booking into a laser treatment
that also means there is this massive
range of how intense laser treatments
are i think a lot of us including me get
a bit scared when we think about laser
treatments we think about lightsabers
and laser eye surgery and pictures of
people with scabby red skin hiding in
the dark for a week after their
treatment and yes this is one form of
laser treatment this is called ablative
laser which means that it purposely
damages the top layer of skin in a
controlled way and this can give really
dramatic results that's why people are
willing to put up with a week of being
scabby and it can take months to finish
healing but now we also have much
gentler laser treatments that don't have
this long downtime and they're also less
risky especially for people with darker
skin one of the biggest problems with
laser treatments when it comes to people
with asian skin like mine or
mediterranean skin or darker so most
people in the world is that our skin
responds to trauma by producing pigment
this is called post-inflammatory
hyperpigmentation or pih so if you're
using a laser to try to blast away
pigment which we often are because
uneven pigmentation is one of the main
ways our skin ages
there is a big risk of causing so much
trauma that you make more pigment form
which is the exact opposite of what you
want to happen you don't want to blast
away a patch of pigment and get the same
patch back or an even bigger patch this
is called rebound pigmentation and it
used to be a massive risk for people
with darker skin when they had more
aggressive treatments like laser but
there's been newer lasers developed that
can treat darker skin effectively with a
much lower risk of getting that rebound
pigment one of the most popular lasers
is the picosaur focus which is the
machine that i was treated with at
neutral bay dermatology the picosure
focus has two special features firstly
there is a really short pulse duration
which means it fires really short blasts
of light into the skin the pico part
refers to picoseconds which is how short
these blasts of light are each one lasts
less than 1 billionth of a second and
that means there isn't really much time
for heat to build up and damage the
surrounding bits of skin and trigger
that rebound pigment it's kind of like
when you take something really hot out
of the microwave and you're too lazy to
get a towel if you go fast enough and
you don't touch it for too long then
there's not enough time for heat to
build up and give you a burn it also
turns out that having these really short
laser pulses means it works a bit
differently in your skin traditional
lasers mostly work by heating up the
pigment until it breaks up but with
picosecond lasers the light turns into
sound instead of heat and the pressure
waves from the sound mechanically
shatters the pigment particles so you
can get really effective breaking up of
the pigment without the same amount of
heat and that risk of rebound pigment
these pressure waves also have a skin
rejuvenating effect so they stimulate
collagen and elastin in the dermis and
that means you can get plumper skin and
smoothing out of fine lines and wrinkles
and shallow scarring and because melanin
is what's turning the light into
pressure it actually works better on
melanated skin this picosecond laser
technology was actually first developed
for tattoo removal and it's only really
become popular for skin treatments in
the last five years or so it's really
cool because it's made it a lot easier
for skin clinics to treat ethnic skin
more effectively and more safely the
other special feature of the picosure
laser is the focused lens array which is
a fractionating head what this means is
that it splits up the laser beam into
lots of little concentrated dots so
instead of treating one big patch of
skin you're treating lots of little
columns of skin again this means the
heat builds up less if we go back to the
analogy of taking hot stuff out of the
microwave when you're lazy it's like how
you try to hold it with little spread
out claws so that there's lots of space
for the heat to dissipate this also
means that you can deliver a lot more
power safely so there's 20 times the
amount of power compared to the original
picosure so it makes it more effective
while also being safer and so all of
this means that the picosure focus is
really good for treating ethnic skin
before the treatment you'll still have
to avoid tanning both real and fake
because it'll get in the way of the
laser but you don't have to avoid harsh
skin care for quite as long i only had
to stop using chemical exfoliants and
retinoids for a couple of days for more
intense treatments you might need to
stop using them for a few weeks plus you
also might need to avoid some
medications like ibuprofen that can
cause bruising now during the treatment
the picasso treatment is really gentle
and painless as far as lasers go now i
am a massive wuss when it comes to laser
treatments the doctors and nurses at
neutral bay dermatology were really
lovely and they reassured me that most
people don't feel much they offered me
numbing cream anyway and i took it
because i figured i'd rather have it and
not need it than chicken out in the
middle here i am looking like the
weekend waiting for it to set in if you
go for the cream you'll have to turn up
about half an hour early they also blow
cold air onto your face during the
treatment and that numbs your face as
well as reducing the risk of damage with
all of this numbing and cold air the
laser felt like a tiny little rubber
band snapping gently against my skin
snapping a bit harder in places where i
had pigment the laser felt a lot more
annoying than actually painful and i
found that with the nurse talking to me
the whole time to distract me it was
very bearable and the treatment was over
really quickly it only takes about 10
minutes
the snapping sound that you can hear is
actually the pigment breaking up i tried
the laser on my not numb hand later and
it felt fine so i think i didn't really
need the cream but from past experience
i've learned that when a medical
professional gives me painkillers i
should always say yes so base it on your
own pain tolerance obviously after the
treatment my face was still super numb
if you go in without any numbing it
feels like a slight sunburn they gave me
two ice packs to hold on my face for 10
minutes to soothe the skin and reduce
the chance of swelling now probably the
coolest thing about the pico shore is
that you have virtually zero downtime so
in other words you can face the world
and do all your usual things pretty much
immediately there's no flaking or
peeling or scabbing your skin might look
a little bit redder afterwards but it
should go away after a couple of hours
my skin looked completely normal you
could barely tell i had anything done at
this stage you might also see that your
pigment is actually a bit darker and
that's because the pigment is more
spread out from all of that shattering
the pigment might get darker for the
next 24 hours and then over the next one
to two weeks the pigment will actually
travel up and shed along with your
normal skin cells which are turning over
in terms of results the picosure is also
quite fast you should see pretty
significant changes after the first
treatment but usually for dealing with
pigment and texture and sun damage it
takes two to four treatments the
treatments should be about two to four
weeks apart so that your skin has time
to shed the pigment before you get
blasted again here are my results after
two treatments i couldn't get the photos
after the third treatment because we
went into lockdown you can see that even
with just two treatments the pigments
faded quite a bit on my cheeks and on
the bridge of my nose it's a bit harder
to see but the pores and texture are
also a lot softer the picosure is the
most popular picosecond laser so it's
been used effectively on millions of
people around the world there's a lot of
research around it there are lots of
clinical trials using the picosure and
you'll be able to find lots of before
and after photos i'm going to be honest
with you i was pretty hesitant to get
these laser treatments at first because
i am just so pathetic when it comes to
painful skin treatments i've turned down
quite a few free laser treatments before
because i was just so worried about the
pain but my experience with the picasso
was really good it was way gentler than
i thought laser could actually be it's
definitely changed my mind about laser
treatments and i would happily do it
again which is not something i thought i
would ever say about laser so i hope you
learned something from this video like
and subscribe if you like skincare and
science and click the notification bell